[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
GameSpot live and Richie and I are
continuing our eight days of horror and
spooky okay it's spooky set the tone for
spooky dreams um thank you guys so much
for tuning in with us and sticking with
us we did like kind of a little bit of a
break in between our spooky days because
of extra life which was totally awesome
and we actually raised so much money for
the Children's Hospital and it went
really really well but now we're back to
get spooked and scared alright so guys
first off I've never played this game
Ritchie never played this game I never
really even heard of this game to begin
with but I just got PS now and they have
a ton of spooky games on there and this
was on there and it almost had a five
star rating like it was a sliver away
from 5 stars so I was like you know what
I gotta try it
views are good yes exactly one of our
one of my twitter friends recommended it
as well when I was asking for some
recommendations those piggy games
so I'm excited I actually know very
little about the Slenderman story I just
know he's very creepy looking and he's
like super tall and slender I guess this
is how he gets his name I know more
about the games just because they've
made like a meme culture territory ever
since people started it like early
streamers would you know stream all this
stuff so I'm definitely aware of the
spooky
well let's kick it off let's go let's
kick it off me yes let's go it's been a
few days since I've played us became we
played a Resident Evil 7 less oh that
was so good I'm still digesting Benjamin
saying hi from the beautiful island in
the Caribbean from a beautiful island in
the Caribbean don't know which one but
hello we are playing on PlayStation this
is available to stream on PS now so I
really am like liking PS now the more
that I use it because it makes me feel
like I'm saving space on my ps4 because
I can just stream the games directly
there's a ton of games yeah oh boy
alright let's give this poppin creepy
car
[Music]
[Music]
hi ho chí from the ug hello thank you
for joining us
something it can't be okay that's as
much context as I need well yeah I know
all right
okay just get my controls down l2 to run
oh when the first thing they teach you
is how to run you know there's gonna be
some problems yep
hello hype step saying hi from the UK as
well thanks for joining
please embrace us as we coupe our
diapers out of fear I'm already spooked
I'm not lying
we're a minute and five into this I like
how it kind of tells us how long way
yeah I wasn't filming this whole thing
camera view though we got full battery
right now yep and I've learned how to
run whoo
and everything I know it's the same time
though a little bit scenes yeah probably
gonna plan like a house or something
first
he's not just gonna show up if he does
yep that's scary
hey guys if you notice we talk a lot
because we're so nervous playing a scary
game but this is how it helps us cope
okay
it's Jerry I'm talking over anything
spooky that possibly happen that's what
I do Sims I'm like oh dang James house
and says scary roads take me home where
[Music]
this is full speed like yes it's like
someone carved it in
Shriram says hello shout out all the way
from India yes thank you for joining
guys and Jonathan just sup to the
channel you rock we appreciate thank you
pick up the sign of the missing sign
then exit the game then go back with
those instructions for a horror movie
all in its own I don't even know what it
means
you're very wobbly I am this is just a
guerilla filming right here what up guys
this is the log abandoned flooring hey
what's up you guys smash that like
button jealous I don't like I says the
calm before the storm
he knows what it is go back oh it's an
easter egg
I see okay you see a sign pick up okay
I'm ready oh it's getting way too
jarring yeah oh boy a flashlight trying
little flowers like I don't know where's
the net it's listening me watch I am
scared
oh there's the sign oh it's a for sale
sign no I do not want to live here
thanks but I'm going in anyway triangle
is the flashlight the door wide open
already hello oh the music change don't
like that let's turn our headphones up
all the way Persia word no no okay maybe
a little war but we're gonna get freaked
out you guys are in for no no no no oh
okay
I thought a light turn on behind the
door but it was just the door you okay I
feel like I'm on an episode of Ghost
Adventures during the lockdown I love
that show so weird I heard weird ass hi
in the middle of no
here's a phone this is not my house so I
will not be dealing with this spirits
are known to speak through the astral
plane by using smoke so yeah - maybe -
chill out here nice cigar
play some chess it's dark yep and yeah
Oh a piano
I just summon new eyes it's a game over
guys
thank you for watching we're about to
die alright we have a lot of fans in the
in the chat that know what to do I know
they're gonna call me out but this is
our first time we got to remind you yeah
if we make our way back outside we're
gonna look for that sign on the tree
event that Aiden was telling us about I
have a scrapbook
but yeah hopefully you guys like the
idea of us not knowing what the hell
we're doing cuz this is gonna get scary
no matter what
creaky a story just scared me thanks for
calling last night it probably sounds
dumb but it was good to hear your voice
again good to hear that Lauren's been
doing well too but yeah about what all
we said I'm not sure what you think of
it yet what are the odds of two people
having the exact same hallucination
could it really just be a coincidence I
have to go to my doctor today or for
some routine stuff so I'm gonna try and
casually bring this up and see what he
says about it I'll let you know how it
goes
signed CR Wow they printed it they
printed a whole Assam email I mean
that's how we get the contact part of
the horror yeah what year is this oh no
the bathroom and done' yes oh wait city
there this game to come out like 2013
yeah that was probably like I just oh
shits about to get real Persia I don't I
don't want I'm breaking and entering a
cop should be here before anything else
when do I get the flashlight it's gonna
keep pressing triangle come on Lucas
says without oh yes I'm trying to be
very careful here don't know what I know
the music stops I'm sorry that's scared
me
oh look as soon as you hit the garage
that's scared yeah I don't know if I
want to go back outside now I feel safe
in here this is now my home I've
squatted here you know that's how they
get you
I need a flashlight there's gotta be one
in this house yeah you know you're in
the garage the garage does sound like a
good place for it
yes where you keep a flashlight or a
cupboard or something
okay you know what let's just carry the
microwave around those oh yeah makes
Gary beeping noises kill slender man
with microwaves yes oh nice breeze it is
so dark we gotta give Slenderman more
opportunities to get inside the house
yeah absolutely
oh yeah I can run okay I'm in the dark
yeah right what was that garage okay
maybe yeah I like the idea
oh the glove boxes a car there's always
somebody in the car
dang it I can't even get in well to be
fair it's not my house or my I can't get
into this car that's not mine why are
you going - nowhere
excellent question our fear cuts off our
brain that's what we were in last time
it's so dark I'm actually just scared
yeah I feel like the house is the place
to be until I find something I'm
wondering why there was aa - music in
the house yeah in the house ooh thank
you chat was that you are dude dude
that's how'd you know that
oh I just saw a window up there and it
was like there has to be a second floor
up there somewhere
oh yeah I just walked right by you no no
we're smart it starts someone left here
in a rush right James who says - dark oh
my god like I think I might have to
adjust something wait this is a bait
that has to be like something I'm going
I'm gonna run get ready for it okay okay
it was just the Fallen like a lamp sets
it's locked
by the way that lamp is not plugged into
anything and it's on so just not okay oh
boy
I can't see the way back my way back oh
you should see a blinking light that
would be the flashlight okay okay so
we're looking for Thank You Aidan what
would we do without you yeah chat it's
cool with the helpful maybe a little
little way to rub it in game I'm going
backwards cuz I don't I need air Omega
we need to talk to keep our sanity
that's why we do this it's way more
terrifying if we don't say anything you
just close the door yeah you are a brave
soul okay it's not in it no oh I thought
you closed it with you inside Oh Dave
have you guys thought of playing Alice
madness Returns I love the original
yeah I remember the first one I never
played returns I remember I when it came
out I'd never picked it up cuz I was
waiting for it to drop in price and then
it just forget what happened it just
whoop that would be fun okay I'm going
in circles me yeah with a little
brightness settings can i I feel like
it's way too dark like I goofed up in
the beginning here we go here we go
maybe one or two more of these one more
spin it all the way up no spooky for you
stream cuz I can't see what the f I'm
doing alright this oh boy I just saw
some blood on the wall what left
Oh oops
Picasa key and a flashlight
ASAP when you start running it really
frees me off because it makes me feel
like your characters panicking yeah like
will you ring her squeaky ass door yeah
he's covered booth Alice game is on sell
for $5 $5 Wow upstairs again okay I have
it wait dude can we look inside that
backpack that's like a brand place for a
flashlight yeah okay back up here a
little more brightness that door is
locked
oh there's another door appears to be
open already
it's so dark is there a light switch
[Music]
pick up that lamp it's wireless after
all wait okay I see a window too
[Music]
it's this is jeez alright we've spent 12
minutes wandering in the dark yeah would
you like to oh my gosh okay
about every 12 minutes we'll swim I
taking a second player here now where
I'm so far in the darkness I can't okay
candy says check the star room start our
room which is the star thank you I
appreciate the subtlety of that hand
you're not telling us like go here do
that that was very like I found a
flashlight let's go huh see ya you
deserve this alright oh man this is
gonna get worse I feel like the second
they give you a resource yep just about
to hit the fan hey a family photo no we
don't time they're gonna be creepy as
hell okay
yes oh gosh three rooms so many rooms
here
this is not cool when you're only a
source of vision is like this little
circle oh I'm just glad the battery
doesn't see up here to drain um well
what was interact there we go through
Dallas this is gonna set this is already
setting us up for some major spookiness
like a feel it's all right Rancic the
room oh Abyan says look out the window
you'll love it no Leonardo says congrats
now you're getting started mmm which
window I'd now I'm gonna look out all of
them which is probably so bad Oh God
that corner of roof just freak me out
no you know what I can't I can't do it I
can't keep yes now for that room down
the hall I'll look at your car keys
maybe there you go you got that run okay
oh okay that's blood
the music change skills
No
[Music]
now maybe that window he wants to look
out that window I picked something out
yeah what the heck house where's my
inventory I think it was that window
okay okay okay all the notes
medium says sometimes Slenderman appears
outside that window oh oh my god oh my
god I scared myself twice cuz this lamp
I don't know it just scared me because
it's okay and you know what the first
three I looked out he wasn't there
that's why it didn't scare me as much
but that's not cool the camera itself
sugar yeah and I felt the vibration over
the controller so I it like definitely
got that semester we're playing
Slenderman the arrival the sequel like
four minutes cuz you're just good at
games and you I was like walking around
like hello and you're like found the
flashlight you've got this Persia
I like that straight up gave me a heart
attack a low-key heart
someone was screaming yeah maybe they
were being dragged away you have a
flashlight now I think you can just be
done with this house but it's up to you
I need a second yes that like actually
got my heart racing it was the whole
culmination of like screen shaking
freaking controller going off
he sent me in the house don't say that
where am i self Jesus I would hear this
I'm so scared I don't even know where to
go anymore
so that was our first intro to like hmm
now we know sort of what's going on here
someone who was screaming I I don't have
no idea what's going on here I don't
want to go over there that's where you
were standing
yeah Leonardo says it's a way to to get
you gently used to jump scares
and out the window thing I can't oh he
better not me inside the windows when
I'm out here cuz that's too much for me
Oh where was that scream coming from
[Music]
this would be me outside this LZ all
right I'm in the backyard and I made it
oh god of course I have to come on here
this is where he was when I freaking
yeah he was past those bricks wasn't he
or was he like you're oh yeah I might be
so tense right now like my shoulders
you're doing great you're making
progress to progress oh my god the mic
just moved by itself a little bit and I
felt it really yes I think it just like
adjusting hmm okay guys it's wide open
I know my freaking my third eye is open
right now
I can't run I don't want to run the
music stopped again I don't know I don't
know see this is how he gets you it gets
you scared makes you run in some
freaking nowhere and what is that a
campfire oh my god doesn't this way I
don't give camping mm-hmm mm-hmm
prepare for the distortions that scare
Oh Lord oh god oh god I wish they didn't
play that yeah and you're like keep
holding down what the [ __ ] I'm sorry but
you're just standing there
menacingly actually don't wanna will not
look at him because then I'm gonna look
back and he's not gonna be there and
then what the frickin frackin y'all you
must cross that little bridge are you
serious setting you up
there was a photo of some guys excuse my
language y'all that I know that was very
aggressive with that that actually just
scared me because he's just standing
there straight up and I have to go that
way oh god I thought he was gonna be
gone when I heard that controller
say be strong pressure get out of here
the sign ah oh no Missy children oh okay
I got the sign for you alien no no no
distortions in the screen no no the
Freak is yet
I'm Shh oh my god okay I haven't been in
a half until it's your turn
me yeah okay you another one oh it's
illuminating the way this is so sus
I'm literally shaking right now you got
cuz I'm like yes everything looks like a
movie high club we are playing
Slenderman the arrival on ps4 it's on
PlayStation now and it's freaking Persia
out so it's perfect for our eight days
of Halloween where I'm so scared more
way more open than I thought of this
game every time I saw like clips of this
game it was indoors maybe I think I'm
something else but being outside might
even be scarier it really is
movie alright well Marjorie okay oh wait
that was only ten minutes seeing it cold
plus 12 is 24 I was just like I cannot
wait mu up the hill
oh yeah I bet I bet you want me to go up
the hill Reggie I can't want you to go
in the other house while she's legal I
can't he's helping you
this is bad because I feel like
everywhere I'm about to look like you're
just gonna be off in the corner maybe
oh yeah movie movie high club it is
available on Xbox one also and it's
called yet slender the arrival
hmm someone left a mess I'm happy cuz
you're at least going the right way
making some progress
[Music]
I was very lost without a flashlight
you're doing great
[Music]
Mike it was
oh no you are tensed up cuz I can't see
yeah what happened where's my flash oh
alright
games over right we did it it's your
visual II you did great
oh that's how they save okay okay I
deserve this extra 20 seconds of freedom
yes why did it go hmm it's really dark
it is mm all right it's so much less
scary when it's not me great you can
help out with know the screen is doing
that on its own
I don't see anything whatever bearded
when you were looking in laughs yeah I'm
being affected oh okay oh yeah I like
that I'll just take this I guess oh my
god everyone said run he's coming oh my
god really no I still can't jump in this
game I'm gonna hide behind this tree no
that sounds like the worst idea ever it
sounds like he lives in a tree no that's
a that's a fence post I'm sorry
terrify me I was like we're looking
around frantically oh boy I am so sure
I'm running for my life y'all hello
alright let's be really guys if this is
you I would just give up okay I've
locked myself in that house just take me
and make it quick yeah there's a tired
of business there's a blinking light
over here I'm gonna go to it campfire
yeah Cyro you better be playing he's
like behind you every little thing
Oh God wee what does it say uh I'm gonna
chill here
don't turn around oh my god noise Wow
I'll run into this sus ass Horace
[Music]
No okay now Chow when I see him do I
just run for my life
no no am I totally dead now then you see
I know
I can't close that door okay those are
my okay I just freaked out
let me so is that the music you have to
run from oh this place looks so creepy
it's getting extra dark this is what
happens in another game like Friday to
the 13 when the enemy is opposed to Oh a
note
great I missed it my footsteps are
giving me away y'all he's gonna find me
he's like look at this lost a smoke
right here oh well the flashlights just
swaying so much I can't this is pretty
good
what if I just take a relaxing bath yeah
alright check it out no flashlight just
kidding not funny okay the the goal said
to find the remaining six pages what run
I'm doing that but I don't know what it
means I'm pressing down the right stick
and it made that sound oh maybe that's
me playing it that you like scared my
tactics get out of here bro more scary
than you yeah
let's find these notes huh out here in
the damn wilderness
what's he up here so Saira said he
actually becomes more aggressive on page
three so your one page Rory I'm really
good right now he's spectating at me
yeah what I find pastries like that's it
you've got too much information now I
still don't like these sounds I know
it's too intense
oh there's one okay I'm gonna get ready
after at line three
leave me alone
oh the music's changing one another oh
my screen I didn't see that nope runway
oh don't your step so this is full speed
oh gosh
alright chat what's the best way to like
avoid him just get distance
just catch me in the afterlife okay oh
boy hey
the Porta Potty nice Espeon oh yes their
note like leave me alone I'm taking a
dump
no no see by my camera's going crazy
Paranormal Activity all the controllers
Persia I think in the heat of this I
should hand you the control no like
three minutes and eight seconds of peace
okay whatever type of peace this is
someone's owed us or no at the tower you
okay there's that damn no I probably
walked by another tower so the first one
that was kind of just like a little
light really okay okay we walked up to
it
it was when he was up on the mountain
good menacingly don't look back at him
for too long that's what Chad says great
okay these are all tips by the way a
reminder that neither of us have played
this game we've definitely heard of it
hey what's up there my camera
there on the right oh my god
you know thank you that on purpose
they've got all these trees so that when
your flashlight hits it just right it
kind of looks like him yeah I've been
mistaken like three or four times oh my
gosh a little breather okay we got to
get to that little tower to get more
notes it's so dark
there wasn't no at the batteries I know
where that is
we were just so frantic that it was like
I tried looking around at all and all
sides at the Porta Potty okay maybe I
should head back there because at least
I know the direction okay
my controller vibrator there I'll find
the other exit it's like not just him
it's the screen Florian's up to you this
is not cool okay dead end yeah I get
together here oh yeah I'm gonna throw up
in there yeah
the only way out seems to be that door
okay I'm gonna side swipe and just run
to the left okay
yeah porta potti was around here
for once let me just try to keep it
quiet
I'm trying take it
it's you
[Music]
back here there dude there's the talent
all right
oh my god oh my god oh he's over there
okay okay man I want he's there but I
need that paper we'll take a long way
around I'm just not gonna look I'm gonna
walk like this
crab walk over there yeah mm-hmm if I
don't see him he's not there right guys
do we come here already yeah
okay he's so close few a severe cameras
going I know
hey mtk where's that page at this hour
this is a tower you're talking about
right
hmm maybe there might be before he's
over there the only need to take it yeah
looking like
Slean slasher over there okay there's
the four diploma and I try to look maybe
I'll try to oh is that it right down the
side oh no that's just
yeah okay
their days it was not like it wasn't
there the first time we look I don't
know yeah okay all right so we got the
one cure it says it's on the leg of that
Tower
okay oh god oh god oh god okay I'm going
back
wish me luck jack yeah we got our GoPro
ready we are there's a little light
source over there now I'm in the
straight upwards okay
I run it Oh Sam it's all trees they're
freaking me out
okay so they said look down at the
bottom of the tower thank you chat
there it is
nope that's a piece of wood
right there that's up here
yeah Oh Suja oh that's means that I
drove that we have five y'all that's me
saying no no no what happened aren't
flashlights is he's siphoning the power
out of our flashlights the more of pages
we sign because that's my stuff okay we
got the one at the tent we're closed
y'all
yeah we're finding more clues we're
finding more dirt on them okay that's
the end replacement me too
I hate that this is full spinning I'm
running for my life jaar will this help
keep in mind guys that were playing with
headphones and it's like it's another
level you guys know what that's like
okay it's not vibrating anymore think of
Oh fries or whatever first are you with
me are you okay
my soul is leaving my body
Thank You chapter like run it's more
difficult
there's a tower again now we're just
going in circles yeah oh you know what I
think it's about your turn I for one
minute okay okay oh god oh god to be
fair though we haven't we haven't died
Oh
maybe we're just lowly dying right now
display yeah
maybe he's microwaving us where I feel
like now I'm only seeing the tower and
the
[Music]
fire little camp where was that building
from earlier
you should find another page if you
follow the path there is no man
chat was right there is no pause button
when you're freaking out like this
oh my god that bit scarier hey over
there alright okay at least we're back
to this area
everyone's like
he's protecting the rest of the pages oh
yeah because we're uncovering the truth
all right here's the path yes it's
wedding a little big guys
Leonardo said watch it he made teleport
in front of you at any time be ready to
turn a baby's back appreciate it as a
car there's no
this one has a bunch of Slenderman
that's the slender squad right there oh
no now I've done it
oh my gosh all right you're officially
at 36 minutes bye thank you guys oh okay
another light is silletti
yeah that means you're aching to play
yeah try reasoning with him I know
thank you down
as Icelander man he likes you purchase a
dead end I'm this is where I die here
let the Soviet swim to our deaths
oh can I Mambo room spins yeah he says
only two wards yes we're closed what
what's that
a boat I'm fine look there
freaking know
that rope okay it's not here
it's just
Oh God my hand is hurting from gripping
the front
oh yeah helped you why isn't this toggle
is that an option oh I can't fly zapper
yeah you can press the menu button are
in the middle
see if there was like turning the run to
toggle instead of having to hold it down
guys this is so bad look you jump you
free
and can't run right now GUP jumped in
and said purchase this all behind outs
you know they're gonna bust down the
door and be like who's screaming I'm
sweating and make it so hard to run it's
so worth about us right Craig says I
would not play at night all my lights on
you know we turn the lights off in here
to try to like make it more scary and
I'm like oh my freaking hand okay I need
your ramp it up I'm grandma foots how he
gets you you make me run for your life
okay Cyrus Cyrus says I'm watching this
in the dark right now you crazy
we're not even playing in the absolute
guard
[Music]
slenderman just wants a hug
come on I'm sure you Slendy hugs
hashtags Lindy hugs yep
two more version you got this this horse
ain't that big ones pretty big but
I feel like over there did Barry to get
that maybe Adam his ham no map or
nothing maybe that he was really close
I'm sweating it's really hot Oh jumping
he and chat was ready Stella Ford ain't
getting really close to this page nice
feeling you've got it don't let him win
we were trying to work out like well you
know you're getting bravery yeah yeah
yeah I'm getting immune to your hand
take splinters yeah it's later man
pelota says he wants friends
I feel like everywhere I go is there
right I can't make any progress
my hand okay I gotta find it okay
cargo containers says the ATM and I'll
try my best to find them it's like if I
stand stilted on he's like that's what
it yeah right up
Kirra says Slendy just wants to
celebrate Halloween by making sports
with you guys
make s'mores out of my brain I rebelled
haha fear how's your hands hurt but I
don't want to stop running haze every
new plz osnap we've found a new spot
right the heck was that over there
lighting up okay okay
cargo crates
we're here Oh God you've gonna really go
freaking
with my time switch it
what is this oh there's definitely a
note here somewhere that means it's
probably closed I keep my camera I
literally can't run anywhere my hand
hurts so bad oh residue as soon as I
intervene it I know those oh he was like
no Ritchie let her suffer
about these are the cargo racer here
definitely miss oh my god
he knows it's you oh no time there's no
rest so aggressive the fact that they
this is not toggle sprint really make
really adds to this okay okay I will
make my way back over there
I can't we gotta take the long way
around
and he keeps chasing us out of the area
la cerveza I switched running hands
we're a nation
I'm gonna die I am going to die I bet
I'm dead I get I did I don't know where
I'm going I can't run anymore I can't
run anymore
you got a trophy that's it insta-kill
you're doing great you see the sweat I
might be I'm literally sweating my
[ __ ] ass off you did great
I'm gonna try to go back in to the cargo
crates grab that damn paper and then
find a lot how far back and your battery
is any of it is it's halfway dude it's
my hand right here he just wants a hug
no I need uh yeah during the day this
should be easier I'm gonna run for my
life and tell ya dude seriously at one
point it was just so hard to run
everywhere and then right at the end
there I couldn't run it all they should
play that Michelle Branch song like
backwards like is your
Oh
so chat since we didn't collect eight
papers this is the nisshin area says
Kira oh right level two is scarier in
the tunnel oh my lord I'm liking this
no goop dill no he said maybe some Hot
Chili vodka hope you likes they took a
shot of that drink extra life because we
got a donation I literally almost threw
up
I've had habanero vodka before in the
past but it was nowhere near like the
heat level of what we took so I thought
I had like an idea of like what it would
be like no was the 1 million times worse
I definitely almost threw up on camera
I'd like to step off for a second and
like breathe Plus that one was aged to
perfection
I'm sure this little kid again okay the
longer you go without a new page the
more aggressive you become
without a new oh great so yeah so like
you have to find it but you also was
gonna chase you away yeah damned if I do
and if I go and now we're in the tunnel
it got dark really fast
yep feel like I can't really run as fast
holding it down yeah maybe it's been
super red my nose was like ready for the
rest of the stream I'm already the only
that's genuine fear we're not playing
warning it's a mining area oh man
still honestly was hurting a bit after
Resident Evil 2 because I was like
Resident Evil 7 because I was like
playing and running a lot in that one
tear I got to bring in the stuff
controller because we can map run to
like this I know I can't jump in this
game I keep forgetting no way 80 in that
that would be next-level stuff right he
says turns out but in the tunnel
someone's alive but she's insane and
she's trying to kill you what I want to
be hearing that
did I miss something okay I just want to
double-check cover my bases okay so I
don't know too much about the actual
story of Slenderman I just know that he
like I don't know convinces people to
like do is bidding or something like
that
so guys you have to tell me a little bit
more about the Slender Man Thor II
theory here oh it looks like he's which
way to our glorious there's the
generators get some light up in here get
to the tower get to the tower we did
already oh I think they mean that big
one that we saw when the game started
I'm just looking out for clues first
before I'd investigate need to get out
any thoughts exactly
they're pointing me this way I'm gonna
check this out real quick no no no no no
but I want to see what did they see
something there yeah is there Slenderman
3 just called it going home I think you
might need power for that my turn
yeah
yep the generator back that yellow thing
yeah here we go
vanilla can see spices watch our episode
of that
okay you're so great he was like looking
around I just want to like only look at
the deliveries and only look at oh you
opened a door over there over here like
it and we did
near the no no no Walt
[Music]
left or right I'm gonna go right hello
what am i doing as a regular a civilian
looking like how did I get involved in
all this
this open no that's a little fuse box
there's too much stuff in here there's
no big generator right there yeah let me
before I go upstairs and meet explore
the rest of this okay every corner is
set up for jump-scare sort of field like
hopefully that was just the cargo lift
that's enough for me oh this place is
massive should I be worried oh my gosh
every time you look into a Holloway I
swear I'm just like mentally seeing
stuff there I'm gonna turn all these on
y'all yeah that's
I know right William there's no hiding
in lockers or nothing you just gotta run
look looks like there are two more
generators to turn Oh
I'm shook but I'm alive let's go
whoo I just jumped back in my chair but
first if that was the reaction they were
looking for ok I'm back here I'm sorry
everyone wearing headphones that was a
different way that was like crazy lady
per se you look at it snipers what's up
cuz that we as Slenderman kind of leads
you up to the jump scares yeah you like
such a camera off a little be like will
appear out in the distance a few times
run up on me
she took my flat ok got a blind her
right I don't like that
does that elevator on now I know can we
get out of here I'm gonna try mom ready
I'm gonna fly in this lady or whatever
it is it's creature
they're not all on you I need to find
two more generators maybe over there in
that creepy dark hallway where you at I
got my flashlight ready okay okay now
you're getting some some setup that's
messed up that first one they just threw
it at us that one back there now it's a
forklift okay here we go
I know these headphones are
this is full speed I hate it I think
when I last looked on Google Food Stamp
this is available at like pretty much on
everything
we're playing oh yeah and PS now has
been like pretty clutch for our horror
game theme streams it's all here because
they've had a lot to choose from so this
is really funny hey these are the stairs
that didn't go up creepy dark hallways
fantastic
nothing made me which I had dog vision
more than games like this these last two
generators man this place is so huge yo
Bob Jones what up Bob Jones in the chat
he says how's it going it's going we're
a little pressed
food stamp this is available on PS now
and possibly I could show your shirt
we're playing on impious nails on the
ps4 I heard some growling gonna be like
right up down here second one oh there's
a generator she's in here she's got it
good
are you act
hello
I hear feet I barely hear feet heck no
don't go and you're gonna get yourself
trapped in your bed now you have to
guess right or left one more my heart is
on fire
nice oh nice going down a little further
here
aha there's another one that I did
already won war Persia how you feeling
horrible I think it's your turn to play
oh my god maybe after that last one we
find what time did I pass it to you at
46 I forget so
okay she doesn't scare me
yeah maybe I read the instructions wrong
because it was like hold r2 and flashed
away there okay they're both here
Morgan I'm not I'm not brave at all that
I'm trying
what's one more generator this is
killing me all okay that's me I'm here
yeah okay Oh
yeah no I'm out of options for you okay
we'll find it did I really go to my
brains off my brain is officially shut
down vote
now they're talking to us
hmm I did go that way it's gotta be down
here could you open a generator and the
other two volleys yeah I didn't go all
the way down here yeah oh yeah out of
here run run run run straight there no
Brent fast for oh my god what yeah no I
will keep playing if you want I will do
it but your but I can't draw miss I'm
gonna make it the whole war ready my
like stomach is on fire whoo Bailey says
focus that flashlight on her face I was
trying to
okay okay good this is this will
probably help us get to that tower or
this might be the tower itself
oh all right
got this
oh she hurt my leg hey hey have we
played SCP containment breach actually
no yeah no I didn't even heard about is
that about Oh triangle your flashlight
why did they turn it off for you
daylight yes daylight
Nate's game is back in the chat so
beautiful oh you kiss the ground Thank
You William
have a good one thank you for tuning in
with us I'm sorry if I blew out your
eardrums you made it further game's over
right guys see you tomorrow my leg is
healed
this is nice and they're even playing
nice music freshest feeling
but I gave you the controller like at
the perfect time this is great
now we're just one for light there's a
tower ah yes
man your camera's run it out what
happens when that happens oh yeah what
does no battery serves what the heck is
that a bear a stuffed bear he throw it
up and
[Music]
that there was a support team oh man I
should have just went to MIT or Charlie
Oh was he that missing kid on the poster
ah oh don't go missing mom mom
open the gate oh why is it blocked by a
rock I know I'm just a little boy just
wait here
that's kidding I know mom will come and
get me once I don't show up right right
guys something sparkly over there see
you this trial babe
this how kids get lost they see
something sparkly off in the distance
what is that a toy a choo-choo train
now I know I'm a child confirmed
Slenderman is luring me away with toys
no I literally only have one path all
right so now we can confirm that it's
not Charlie's fault he got kidnapped
lost whatever mom and dad clearly then
put a gate here for me to get back to
the house you're responsible for those
people sitting right here I think so
just likes weird silhouettes mom I'm
gonna gate Nate's game says someone's on
the hill yeah
that appears to just be your parent nope
I'm pretty sure you're supposed to get
lost see this is actually the negligence
of the parents right there irresponsible
don't move until mom shows that oh yeah
because I will do it mom yeah let me
mommy mom mom
all right some slender man's grace
victim he's roaring in me away with toys
great there's another one
sparkly toy yeah he wants me to leave my
mommy back story all right ready ready
it's official we cannot blame the
parents disappearance see mom's calling
me but you did all the negate nope
you lost your chance and you didn't even
notice that I'm not by your house
anymore oh that looks like a point in
their mind I know like I can't even get
back oh yeah yes the life of a toddler I
jumped down a little ledge and it's over
for me that is so sad and unfortunate
you're going the right way though yeah
yeah just like that
right right Nathaniel they said come
inside and they didn't even let me in
right there the gate we were ready to
oblige
although slenderman giving me only toys
wait a minute spec I'm to the child Oh
another clue Oh another point of no
return
Yolo what was your name again Charlie
Charlie
she sounds way close yeah why I think
that's Slender Man :
oh not here dad fine no I'm not getting
irresponsible
are we on the other side of house it's
getting spooky er
[Applause]
Oh No yeah that's a big boy when I was
ten I don't think I was this dumb saying
[Music]
all right I better enjoy the sound of my
parents whose voices and you last time
in Heroes yep rolling I'm gonna die
Slenderman is gonna show up rolls got
the countdown goodbye world it's behind
you leave Oh probably
it sounds very big Oh a dead end
stay right here you run or you stay
that's horrifying
all right I liked that better than him
just popping out like you're mine
yeah we have the back story because it
was pretty tame yep
yeah Gigi for Charlie press estimates at
Charlie's and let's get those parents
into jail for they're no good again yeah
are you Charlie now all grown up I know
right that was actually me the whole
time like my amnesia is gone and I
remember all of a sudden I enjoy
oh god that scared me with anything like
slender and like black with like a
little piece of white on it yep they do
that on purpose
oh the last one thank you can't ef4
charlie
I can't right now don't worry we added
it to the scrap scrap look of horror Bob
Jones yeah that screamed from Charlie
was particularly loud louder than mine
earlier and it's getting dark I don't
yeah boy I don't know I think it's the
way into like yeah I guess it's Harry
who was here before is it just lender
man setting up oh boy oh boy
Oh Eddie and says no you're Charlie's
friend
and now Roland says we have to go back
into the mine shaft you're heading the
right way towards the power ok y'all
catch that another one that's a little
one Adam thanks for joining us the game
is not new but we have never played it
it's Slenderman the arrival there you go
again those receipts finding out the
stuff we got it on tape not to watch the
evidence remember there were tapes in
resident evil also tapes are always
closed Adam see yeah you remember
watching these visit number 19 my name
is CR Matheson family farm
continuing my investigation and
Charlie's disappearance
let's see what we can turn out
okay I mean you brought Madonna
baby please you don't have a flashlight
gee thanks game
[Music]
like that
[Music]
they made it really difficult to get in
here which means running away is gonna
be hard - you got this Persia someone
about it right now yeah I was like my
brain can't do this
yikes
man this was Charlie's house no wonder
you ran away but scary in here
see much this is like the background is
like beautiful and scary like that time
of day
not the time to start an adventure yeah
defense then there's the main house and
then the second house seems calm here
[Applause]
this is the last 20 minutes of the game
no way maybe I don't know tell us yeah
how do we get our scrapbook I know I
don't even know where the scrapbook is
maybe is it what about the d-pad itself
I need buttons or is it just directional
around oh nevermind hmm okay use the car
I Drive it into the house that's cool
yeah
alright let me see where were the stairs
yeah was there access to them I think I
just probably was so scared I missed it
I like I don't see anything would you go
left and then left again
what was it dead end yeah oh yeah geez
oh the wooden house you mean like that
little barn outside
oh yeah there's another one yes the barn
okay let's do it
although I stopped in there briefly but
I was there a second story maybe a
ladder on a right side tamerlan yeah
these graphics we learned though that it
doesn't even matter here we go we're
getting freaked out no matter what okay
all right throw that in the garbage
I really wanted to set that place on
fire there you go ah thank you chat sky
Lord what's up I was like keep in mind
that uh there's a little delay and achai
in the stream so like if you see us
respond here like super late and like a
run around in circles though yes it
happens it be like that what it is not
super direct okay I mean no fuel there's
making us do yard work and all right
thanks slender man just wanted a short
time this is the farming simulator
we're actually sindermann thundermans
TaskRabbit okay they probably wanted me
to go in that climb about no way yeah
there's got to be fuel nearby don't go
into the tall grass won't tell me things
like that
come on rolling I was in a shower if
he's right though we're gonna feel silly
they're alright they want they've all
played this and they know what's going
on when they enjoy the torture Hoddy in
the chat hi how are you actually thank
you for joining us this mission is
pretty ho-hum so far pretty chill bill
as soon as oh my damn mouth it's really
dark right there I'm scared wait there
was another door over here anything cool
oh no it's on the other side of the
fence
Nate's game says go in the main menu if
you want to view the scrapbook if you if
you if you want there it is oh we don't
know you mean like it takes you all the
way out of the game yeah come on we
gotta find this is he getting darker as
it just means it gets darker when you go
in there I don't like that all right
there has to be another way to the fuel
oh wait I should check car the car
probably I spilled on it great it's the
biggest nope when you walk in there and
they just get starter the whole rooms
grumbling oh that's definitely where the
fuel is then you'll there's the gas door
nope I need to go in okay great you're
beer-fueled thanks Ellie on are you
phony I could use the fear to feel that
thing alright let's go in you have to do
it oh boy it's right I'm harder to run
the closer I get to this building I'm
not weird yeah maybe you definitely are
going the right way
and they don't give you a flashlight I
hate this sound like where the yes and I
shut off this light no no it's so dark
it's so scary too if I can't tell if
there's a door there
sounds like my stomach I got I can't I
can't do I just go in and stand here
fear right oh no it went totally
pitch-black yeah I like sort of Oh got
the beginning of us stick oh I can't
tell it's a dark one of floods the
brightness in the settings
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
Nate's games saying you need the
generator to light this place up no that
little jug oh it's a wastebasket the
fuel has to be around here somewhere
yeah help us out with the fuel chat
we're drowning y'all actually a lot less
spooky yeah other levels but honestly
also don't just feel like my brain turns
off after being scared to a certain
extent so this is the perfect time for
you to play then you're just like I
thought so too but now
hmm here Ritchie is your turn now good
enough okay I definitely played 12
minutes worth
y'all hear that child sounding scream I
didn't wait we're in the tall grass I
thought we weren't supposed to go here
yeah just wanted to see what the limits
are and if we die we die but I just
wanted to see me what else
over here what are we missing you know
they program this area for a reason oh
yeah they didn't mention courts well
that's probably for the future let's go
get the fuel these gates would be so
easy to hot that's why I'm like huh
oh that's just I thought there was like
a little dry waivers in the back your
team just kidding hey there's a one of
those fan houses okay just got to find
the fuel friends Roland if you hear some
weird sounds don't check back
protip there needs to be a sprint button
yeah cuz my handlers rollin said go
right I don't know where I will point
that but uh back here to the sign in
here said uh walk towards the Sun walk
towards the side yeah it was going that
way I think the sun's over there like in
the field over here more right back
there yeah that's where I was ah
check out the windmill yeah go left left
okay yeah yeah I just got to get through
this don't I yeah okay for the windmill
let's go
I just wish I could run faster for y'all
I know I see guys getting tired
alright cool we're going towards the
windmill it's moving there must be some
sort of yeah resource there's activity
in there maybe we can get some wind fuel
Nate's games were on the way bro we are
in routes to the windmill and he's just
walking slower and slower the more we
get here so the basement in the windmill
us now this is getting real oh my god
you gotta take a creepy basement stairs
you got it good of course
can you walk
did you just get locked inside no but it
went dark and Oh
[Music]
no okay no no yep
No
okay every time it flickers out I just
stop walking I don't want to get super
lost left or right definitely left this
is the beat this is what they do there's
the fuel matter here I don't have a
flashlight I don't have a damn
flashlight yeah I didn't get out
I just don't want to get lost stop there
we go
we're lost we're lost no yeah oh my
goodness
dodge miss me with that chat uh look at
the good looking out don't panic but
also don't check your lives naturally
did that so Erica there's the tall grass
maybe that's why everyone was telling me
[Music]
Larry the lobster we do read observe
there's just a delay so if we actually
are delayed to what you think all right
who know my scary music we got to get to
that generator you had the fuel that did
not sound like a job well done so they
were right though it lit up this whole
barn
let's go sort of very poorly actually
hey if he's a paper well actually it
would be very helpful
no you're gonna die in this room area
I'm gonna hug the wall here see you're
about to bump into it
that's cool man bring them on because
I'm not getting any answers y'all I'm
hugging the wall there's nothing else in
this room okay all right all right we're
after this room yeah yeah wait I
couldn't reach that paper oh you prizes
are
oh here we go these are interesting
sound effects there's the paper okay hey
oh look it's Charlie and his family and
bad times okay this is the wait see I
was stuck out there now I'm in here
let's go if you see a Slenderman pig
don't walk into it we definitely 1
million prison walked into it
oh I ever really did was it that Chuck
John that one nope I'm interested
curiosity I've never heard that second
half okay hmm burned down cemetery Larry
said don't die appreciate you Larry
thank you rolling inside we're on edge
it's hard oh yeah
which way should I go they said we have
to find a key oh yeah for that padlock
all right Chad help us out
really yeah I'm out of here okay now I
know exactly where you go the gate let's
go I wish I could jump this dumb fancy
bar oh yeah it is
absolutely they make you do this right
time up this ladder that's not a ladder
okay Wow
they said the key was in the world to
start the Flint plan
we found a random key on a wheelbarrow
oh really yeah they rollin was saying
there's a key in them in the little
house maybe that one we really can't the
picture in hmmm why I have a key I'm
just gonna try well let's go unlock the
gate and then maybe we can get through
there go around the side no I like the
grass no we're definitely in there
you're walking the path that is in the
grass now there's no Larry the lobster
kid no Adam my soul would not be able to
handle playing
now we got three minutes left of the
street versus it
no that is had nope nope let's go right
in then I'm scared oh we have stamina
nope
three minutes I like that option I give
up okay okay three minutes are you gonna
or is this it
you know my my soul has left my body
god I'm seriously I was stressful we
only have two minutes left of the
broadcasts you guys so we can either
give it another shot for last two
minutes or I just call it call it there
call it you're it's up to chat yeah I
definitely need this buffer right now
cuz whatever yeah this break is just
giving personal life she's getting her
color back and her soul this is the last
five minutes all right if it really is
let's let's do it okay let's do it okay
retry for the two minute snakes
Nate's games would you like to or would
you really I don't want to Ford I don't
this is a wait oh no no we're just
outside of that spooky house here we go
we know last five minutes of the game
you got it you got it
now do I take the toys and run for my
life or do I just
did it lock me in it's playing out so
differently this time I can't even pick
up things oh he's gone oh now look now
I'm missing a mom right I'll take the
baby and all of your dumb toys
it's open now yeah that's a tree yeah
yeah cats always like don't look back
I'm just curious okay what do I do now
have his baby
first I can't right now you know the
first time we went such a different way
and I was expecting it to be that way
yeah then yeah totally different hey you
better chill the chats gonna
automatically stop you okay from one
spooky house to another they do not
recite I'm gonna write away where if
we're getting closely at the end of the
game I got no time to lose
gimme that maybe I shouldn't even pick
those up huh
maybe I have to to continue the story
[Music]
really done for it now still no
flashlight
[Music]
see I told didn't ice call it in the
beginning they made it really hard to
run away yeah like it's all difficult to
get in the house I was full speed you
have to take all the toys terrifying for
me just like watching I don't understand
Thank You chat we will pick up all those
toys this time appreciate your your tips
and tricks cuz I don't know what I'm
doing y'all oh man I do I really need to
pick up all of ya does he really have to
go cuz I'm just gonna wing it again go
back I don't think yeah they wouldn't
put me here if I needed to go back
that's my thinking just run yep and then
if this time it really doesn't work out
then we'll go back for it go and I'm
going full speed
[Music]
different hey I think I did it and
that's the story playing out you think
well didn't look yeah we were meant to
see that Nate I can't hold myself up
right anymore we're breaking down here
to friend ok so that was us watching the
tape there's another tape on the table
really over your left oh boy tape number
three I like I know should I have done
that
well rollin said words words like the
last five minutes oh okay of the game
that Zeebo oh gosh you guys we got
bamboozled Persia
okay I do
we're oh this is the house in the
beginning
it's close already
full speed and by stamina drop yeah why
do I have a feeling that no matter what
my god close it is okay walking
simulator that would the trophy was
that's close let's go
then I clearly closed this all Emily
okay there's the front door wide open I
know what the heck
it's shaken is in here sucks it's
raining who let all these windows open
Nathaniel's saw him oh my god you saw
him and we didn't oh my god oh my god I
gotta go upstairs
with my room
[Music]
okay go it go that's the one we unlocked
we did it barely what that I don't even
know what that means that was not the
room and that was not our room
what really I died no no I was just
saying that first our swimming oh my god
I almost blew it okay we're close to the
end are we we have to be have to be we
learned a lot from those tapes but now
okay Percy's got the final wing of this
because I'm just gonna assume we're
gonna die
first you're right you've got it we're
going to the tower where is it actually
there you go I don't know it's probably
mindless cliff or something
[Music]
I don't yeah what's up women perhaps
know looked like it oh I'm gonna die yes
yeah where we came from
this is where we're going
dang it
[Music]
is this the Krusty Krab
all right it has to be here
ah all right
so strange was there anything else
I really have going back yeah back home
because that would really suck but we do
know that our is up there
Roland even he's like I can help you
guys I forgot this part 5 minutes all
right so back together we now we're
going and blind
can't can't okay
about the right right now oh that was
just the TV
what the heck hmm
[Music]
come get me Slenderman Tomas yeah
what the Oh is there a path along there
are my tripping now I think you all will
see ya know what the heck
holy smokes
okay
uh-huh uphill wait yeah yeah there we go
how's that always happens to me I'll
like get lost finding the easiest thing
there it is shoe number 12
oh boy Xander hey you just caught us in
the last bit of the stream here we're
trying to wrap this up wizard again with
the hardest difficulty rough we never
played this I don't even think it gave
me that yeah but yeah neither of us the
plays in I need to see the option either
nothing I remember yeah it just said
like start game where I likey that hmm I
can't even tell which part is the path
anymore I just know I gotta get over
there
no way yeah broke the game if you did
that would have been so is it what you
came oh yeah that dumb little tree was
in the way
okay
let's go back back go back no no it's
all looking the same to me now don't go
anywhere with me you guys you'll get
lost all right
although they they put this path here
for a reason maybe that was like we went
up and then we went down like to the
others oh we're all still just talking
about the mountain Hey so we'll remember
this is Wailing up and then yeah this is
the other side so I go up like leaping
me back around
Nate's game says in GTA you'd be rag
dolling at this point if you were
climbing such a steep I know it's true I
thought we were like breaking the game
in Windows yeah it is funny to hear
Franklin screaming I just love I said
just jump out of planes and San Andreas
when in grand theft auto san andreas is
here CJ like yeah well really plenty
okay maybe this just looks this to me
that's not actually the same spot
Zep a different place I can't tell if it
looks like
I think we're going the right way
nope dang it alright okay
okay yeah this is the real puss those
windows finding out where to go in the
home what the ass and my hand hurts um
run Thank You Kaden thanks for joining
us we are running a little bit over time
but we heard we were close to the end so
really why not just try to finish it
mtk says it's a cave at the top that's
what we're looking for
oh I think I found the right path here
this looks good yes good about left that
little hump is that oh I don't maybe
don't yeah there you go yep it's all
starting to look the same though see
this is taking me back around has to be
up
hmm it's not oh my god lost we're lost
in the woods this is the actual scary
part you know what I think that battery
signifies the progress we made in this
game to the same please I'm looking for
a cave they said so maybe it's just up
here in the walls yeah oh there is oh
that's so long fine but we found it
alright alright here we go Oh flashlight
that gives me anxiety
oh he did that on his own yeah where is
it she don't forget who were playing
well that box
[Applause]
okay there's a little CR the homie I
feel like we saw have a lot left over
yeah what the Oh
he's laughing at us laughs writing on
the wall
[Applause]
we're really glow foods our than can
make it
oh my god what why he's behind me he is
behind me oh my gosh
Smokey the Bear
now they changed it from Slenderman to
smoke Oh Oh God this isn't fair this
fire oh my gosh you can't run
everything
the treat you gotta you gotta you're so
much
get ready to dodge there
the freaking key nobody's nobody's here
but everything's locked
[Music]
[Music]
Amy Harris SPS we walked the door in
oh my god oh my god
fine oh my god
wait there myself
I thought the game was just teasing you
they liked me you know what to do now
man oh yeah click the I give up button
press shook y'all alright it's not
lowercase F sad it's a little yeah I
retracted it freeze it looks like no a
little bit is the game telling us I do
feel like we were close to the end
though there for a second
yeah it is oh yeah
it literally froze like we're actually
trying to fix it but um hmm all right
well you guys we got really close in and
if that really was the last two minutes
like Roland says and we probably just
had to like run through that building
and make it to the tower and then we're
free let's just assume so let's just
assume though in my eyes we beat that
game alright yep um thank you guys so
much for tuning in I apologize again I'm
so disheveled that's what they're here
for
it's crazy yeah literally the game is
frozen and did I close it out and
restart it's gonna be a lot of work
we're also re 20 minutes over time but
it was worth it I think we got pretty
far and it was fun but also like whoo so
scary at the same time like scary in the
worst ways like I would see like
Slenderman and like other characters
weren't like visually that terrifying
but the way they were like popping out
and where they would show up that was
everything the controller was shaking it
so loud with our head we can't we're so
close but the game froze you guys sorry
throws it the worst time the worst time
cuz Ritchie actually hit retry yeah ok
well thank you guys so much for tuning
in tune in tomorrow we are going to be
playing more spooky games we lost
days of our eight days in total but it's
fine Halloween is a on Thursday so we
suggest name so yeah
tune in tomorrow and the next day for
some more spooky stuff and have a good
one you guys